on va parler du nucléaire nucléaire
dernier thème de ce club mais plus
précisément des conséquences de la
sécheresse et des chaleurs élevé de ces
derniers jours sur nos centrales c'est
notre reportage à votre rencontre on va
aller à la centrale du planier du 5 au 9
mai dernier elle a dû réduire son
activité en cause la température trop
élevée de l'estuaire de la gironde alors
le réchauffement des fleuves menace-t-il
à terme la filière nucléaire on regarde
ce reportage de samia de chair sang os
pas de centrales nucléaires pour le
refroidissement l on puisse dans une
mère ou un fleuve elle en ressort
ensuite un peu plus chaude jusqu'à une
certaine limite si la température du
fleuve est trop élevé il faut réduire
l'activité du réacteur voir l'arrêter
totalement pour ne pas mettre en danger
la biodiversité en réchauffant davantage
le cours d'eau c'est ce qu'il s'est
passé pendant six jours en mai sur la
centrale du blayais en gironde
pour l'instant ces pertes de production
ne représente que 0,3 pour cent en
moyenne par an de la production totale
du parc nucléaire mais edf surveille de
très près l'impact du réchauffement
climatique sur les fleuves qui bordent
ses centrales ces baisses qui sont je
dis aujourd'hui réduites en quantité
assez marginal c'est vrai il faut
s'attendre à ce qu'elles augmentent
qu'elles soient plus fréquentes on part
heureusement d'une proportion très
faible elle pourrait effectivement être
augmenté d'un facteur 2 peut-être d'un
facteur 3 mais vous voyez qu'en moyenne
on va rester autour du % donc c'est
baisse effectivement sont regardés de
très près mais ne nous inquiètent pas
outre mesure moins de 1% un chiffre
rassurant mais cette moyenne cache des
pics bien plus important cas de fortes
chaleurs petit boulet qu'on a réalisé
pour rtl une étude sur l'impact du
changement climatique sur le système
électrique français à l'horizon 2050 ce
qui est plus préoccupant c'est la perte
de puissance disponible à un instant
donné à un instant donné on peut avoir
jusqu'à combien de réacteurs combien de
centrales qui ne sont pas en mesure de
produire et donc là actuellement on va
jusqu'à des pertes de l'ordre de 6
gigawatts et c'est 10% des réacteurs ou
10 % de la puissance installée qui n'est
pas disponible à un instant donné à
l'horizon 2050 dans mario ou le
nucléaire reste reste une source
d'énergie importante en france on pourra
avoir des pertes plus importantes de
l'ordre du double dans un scénario
démission on dirait dans l'ain la
centrale de bugey est particulièrement
concernée elle était 2018 la canicule
fait monter la température du rhône
provoquant un arrêt de plus de 600
heures sur deux des réacteurs et ce
genre d'épisode pourrait devenir
récurrent car à l'horizon 2040 et en
2070 la température du fleuve va
augmenter de plus de 2 degrés pour les
opposants au nucléaire il est absurde
d'envisager la construction de nouvelles
centrales dans ces conditions pdf ne dit
pas ce qui se passe réellement dans
leurs réacteurs faut savoir quand même
que chaque année il ya 30 à 50 réacteurs
qui décrochent subitement du réseau est
effectivement avec ses baisses de temps
enfin ces arrêts nécessaires à cause des
débits ça va encore accroître le manque
de réacteurs sur le réseau donc il faut
se pense et se poser la question si on
doit investir dans des installations
aussi cher pour qu'elle ne marche pas à
plein dans les années à venir quoi parce
que les règles européennes qu'on veut
nous faire c'est quand même la filière
énergétique la plus chère actuellement
de tout quoi edf assure que les futurs
repères seront tous équipés de tours
aéroréfrigérantes comme le sont déjà les
réacteurs les plus récentes qui rejette
une eau beaucoup moins chaude que les
anciens mais l'autre menace qui pèse sur
les fleuves c'est leur débit d'ici 2050
il pourrait baisser de 10 à 40% selon
les régions et les saisons une ressource
tendue qu'il faudra partager entre les
centrales nucléaires les agriculteurs
les industriels et les particuliers à
l'argentine on le voit dans ce reportage
un double menace qui pèse sur les
fleuves et au réchauffement climatique
qui a le réchauffement de la montée de
la température des fleuves et puis il ya
la baisse de leur niveau est ce que ça
va avoir des conséquences sur nos
centrales nucléaires et sur la filière
nucléaire française c'est un marronnier
qu'on nous ressort absolument tous les
étés ses conséquences oui allez y en
aura mais on peut parfaitement s'y
adapter et pour parler clair elles sont
parfaitement minimes il faut comprendre
comment comment ça fonctionne tout
simplement quand on parle de la perte de
débit des fleuves sur notre parc
actuellement il y en a huit qui sont
effectivement situé sur le rhône qui est
un parc à fort d un fleuve à faire des
biens ses 900 mètres cubes d'eau par
seconde de débit ça tombe à 600 mètres
cubes par seconde au mois d'août quand
on prélève 50 mètres cubes pour le
refroidissement de la centrale s'est
passé pas un problème même si le débit
devait baisser de 40% les autres et les
30 autres réacteurs qui sont bord de
deux fleuves oms on fonctionne avec des
débits plus faible fonctionne en circuit
fermé c'est à dire vous avez ces tours
aéroréfrigérantes convoi on prélève très
exactement 2 mètres cubes par seconde
pour compenser la vapeur d'eau qui
s'échappent des tours aéroréfrigérantes
ça ça veut dire que techniquement pour
la sécurité de la centrale ça fonctionne
jusqu'à un débit de fleuves qui est de
31 mètres cubes par seconde donc vous
imaginez la marge qu'on a sachant que
les seuils de sécurité sont quand
portrait au dessus donc c'est pas
réellement un problème hormis pour
quelques centrales précise je pense à
golfech par exemple qui est dans ta
nekaies tarn et garonne soit sur la
garonne qui est qui est très affecté par
le réchauffement climatique
là ça pourra être un peu plus tendue
épisodiquement mais on peut pas parler
d'un problème de long terme a par
ailleurs les centrales les futures
centrales seront adaptés je vous
rappelle que la plus grande centrale aux
états unis celle de palau paulo verde en
arizona et en plein désert et elle
fonctionne avec les eaux usées de la
ville de phoenix pour son circuit de
refroidissement donc dire que le
réchauffement ça va être un problème
c'est franchement pas une réalité puis
quand j'entends des militants il y là il
a raison de dire que il faut se poser la
question de l'adaptation est ce que
c'est la dépense la plus la plus
d'intelligence en 2003 pendant la
canicule de 2003 j'ai regardé ça hier
soir les pertes de production liés à
cette canicule ont été de jeu leino et
1,2 pour cent du total de la production
quand on sait que le l'éolien par
exemple ne fonctionne qu'à qu'à 20% de
son rendement que le photovoltaïque il y
en a pas la nuit
voilà il faut balancer les
dix militants c'est absurde d'envisager
la construction de nouvelles centrales
pour vous c'est pas absurde ça c'est
c'est pas absurde
tout a été dit
et bien dit ce qui m'inquiète plus si
vous voulez c'est l'espèce de dommartin
qui qui règne sur l'avenir de notre parc
nucléaire sur son entretien sur la
nécessité de est bien de remettre
certaines certains réacteurs et donc
certaines centrales
2 les deux les deux les deux de les
restaurer afin de les remettre je dirais
de les moderniser pour les pour que pour
les rendre
plus pérenne tout ça ça me ça m'inquiète
beaucoup je trouve qu'on n'a absolument
pas de transparence sur l'entretien de
ce parc nucléaire et que le débat il
porte sur ce qu'il faut du nucléaire ou
pas je pense que ce débat là il est
derrière nous parce que il faut du
nucléaire c'est une énergie qui alla qui
a beaucoup davantage même si elles
présentent un danger certain mais dans
un pays comme le nôtre je pense qu'on
peut le maîtriser et en revanche il ya
une espèce de 2,2 de voile
qui est entretenue par la direction
d'edf par la direction par le
gouvernement aussi les gouvernements qui
se sont succédé sur l'entretien de ce
parc de centrales
c'est pas tellement que c'est au pas on
a quand même une autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui est parfaitement indécent
sûr et
aussi surtout par les gouges le
gouvernement actuel et les gouvernements
successifs qui ont tellement nier la
nécessité du nucléaire il était sur une
optique on en sort on réduit par deux du
coup on a sous investis on a pris
énormément d'argent à edf pour financer
le système de régulation des prix qui
est un peu complexe la reine mais on va
pas y revenir mais on a on a grévé
pendant des années les capacités
d'investissement d'edf qui a
effectivement aujourd'hui problème on le
voit dans le nombre qui a trompé trop
élevé de réacteurs qui sont arrêtés
alors beaucoup le son pour maintenance
mais beaucoup pour des problèmes
la plupart se sont quand même pour
maintenance 1 milliard des problèmes de
corrosion et on voit on voyait un
sous-investissement général et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement qui est dans
une autre petit qui a réalisé finalement
son erreur et qui se dit bon bah en
catastrophe par qu'on maintienne le plus
longtemps possible les réacteurs
existants ouvert minimise aussi ce
problème là dans tous les plans du
gouvernement qu'on a vu pour l'instant
c'est on part du principe que bat tous
et toutes ses centrales on va pouvoir
les prolonger jusqu'en 2050 2060 n'en
sais rien l'examen des sénats l'isf et
tous les dix ans il y en a probablement
certaines qu'on ne pourra pas restauré
et qu'on devra fermer et ça
effectivement il va parfaitement raison
c'est un gros tabou qui n'a pour
l'instant pas été posée dans débat
public je pense que agnès pannier rue
nash et qui sera chargé de ces questions
on a une conscience assez aiguë mais la
question va se poser elle va se poser
assez rapidement ouais il ya un autre
sujet aussi qui va se poser
géraldine c'est le sujet des déchets
nucléaires ça aussi c'est une question
ça c'est un sujet explosif à venir il ya
le président de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui est un des leurs et au
sénat il faut bien versé un sujet il est
explosif mais pas pour les raisons qu'on
donne souvent dans le débat public quand
on parle de déchets faut bien savoir de
quoi on parle il ya une grande masse de
déchets parmi ceux ci il ya une toute
petite partie qui représente 3% du
volume des déchets mais 95% de leur
radioactivité
se lasser d'échelle à la question allait
régler c'est le projet cigéo
d'enfouissement sur le site de bure il
ya eu des années des années de débat
public ce projet va se faire il faudrait
qu'il se fasse maintenant assez vite
mais ce problème est réglé ce qui n'est
pas réglé c'est la question des piscines
d'entreposage des déchets des
déchets à
faible activité radioactive qu'il faut
entreposés et ils ne seront plus du tout
radioactifs cela dans 300 ans et
effectivement on
les sites vont arriver à saturation en
2030 il faut construire deux nouveaux
sites d'entreposage et sa balle l'ordre
a pas été donné il faut donner landes
pour déconstruire ces longs à construire
il faut qu'on fasse mais c'est pas un
problème en soi c'est un problème de
décision politique et en supplément un
poison fn je sais parler de
procrastination et oui un programme il
faut il va bien falloir les mettre
quelque part et pour ça il faut lancer
mais c'est pas des déchets dangereux
cdpa ils le sont mais c'est la patrie
mère opérationnel fait ça c'est si il ya
une filière enfin en fait c'est ce sont
des sites d'entreposage pour attendre la
décroissance radioactive de ces déchets
qui je redis c'est à peu près 300 ans
ensuite madame maintenance partie des
déchets c'est le plus de 30 % des
déchets qui sont ce qu'on appelle des
très faible activité
qui en fait en france on a une
conception administratif du déchet c'est
à dire qu'on considère comme déchets
nucléaires tout ce qui était sur un site
que ce soient radioactifs ou non et
parmi ceux là il ya les ce qu'on appelle
à très faible activité certains ne sont
pas du tout radioactifs on l'est on les
met simplement dans des sacs et on les
entreposent pour l'instant ça représente
500 mille tonnes à peu près mais avec le
déménagement tellement des futures
centrales le nom de ces déchets ça y va
exploser on s'attend à deux millions
deux millions et demi de tonnes de ces
déchets qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
l'allemagne les etats-unis la suisse la
belgique ils les recyclent en france on
les recycle pas est-ce qu'il faut
changer la loi c'est assez un vrai débat
on n'a pas encore eu mais qui va aussi
devenir assez pressants ils crise de se
reposer merci
[Musique]